the reason the truth the votes research
i think is so powerful here is they set
such a high bar 10 or more drop boxes
because see let's say that they had set
a bar of two drop boxes now nobody has a
reason to go to two even if you have
your family members ballots you're gonna
go put them in one drop box but some guy
was gonna come forward and say well you
know what i i put my ballots in the
first box i had to tie my shoe at the
second box so you're calling me a mule
i'm not a mule so instead of all this
nonsense set a bar of 10 or more drop
boxes let's remember these are this is
in the post office this isn't where you
go to drop your bills off these are only
for balance there's no other reason to
go to these drop boxes other than to
dump ballots and why would you go to 10
or more drop boxes unless you were
stuffing them with ballots
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an author podcast host and creator of
the new film 2000 mules which is out
right now dinesh d'souza welcome back to
the reuben report
dave it's a real pleasure thanks for
having me back i'm looking forward to it
it's been a couple years since we've
chatted on camera my friend but i feel
that we have to give a warning right up
top here there is a good chance that my
channel will be blown up on youtube
because of this
but
i did create locals you launched 2 000
mules on locals which i obviously want
to get into and i'm honored that you did
that and anything that we cannot put on
youtube for this interview we will put
up well i'll just say we'll put it up on
both our channels fair enough
i mean dave what a surreal time we live
in i i don't think you and i would have
predicted a decade ago that we would
find that these basic liberties which
are supposed to be outside the bounds of
politics free speech rights for example
would somehow be abridged in this way
and we'd have to
watch what we say and figure out should
i put this up i have exactly the same
issue with my daily podcast
and with this movie you know i couldn't
put the trailer up on youtube i couldn't
buy ads on facebook so i had to develop
an entirely different business plan for
releasing this movie as compared to any
of my earlier ones
so let's get into that business plan in
just a moment but first let's let's
focus on the movie itself i was at the
i suppose it was the pre-premiere of the
movie which was at mar-a-lago and it was
sort of a of a who's who of uh let's say
right-wing media or whatever you want to
call all of us at this point
and i got to see the movie i thought it
was excellent many people on my book
tour one of the questions that i got
more than anything else over the last
couple weeks was what did you think of
the movie and i recommended that
everyone see it make some judgments for
themselves
what was the initial starting point of
when you were did you want to
immediately ask questions like the night
of the election or was it a couple weeks
later what was sort of the genesis of
the whole idea well like a lot of people
i i noticed the anomalies of 2020 and
they struck me as really strange but
once the curtain well once biden was
inaugurated and then of course a curtain
of censorship descends on this topic i
thought man you know we probably will
never find out what really happened in
the 2020 election with each passing day
the event becomes more remote and and i
was dissatisfied with the rhetoric a
little bit on both sides now you know
start with the left the most secure
election in history and i thought to
myself even before i started anything
with 2 000 mules well how could you
possibly know that and they'd be like
well dinesh where's your proof of fraud
and i'm like well let's say i had none i
have no proof does it make it the most
secure election of all time i mean right
these are still separate things yeah you
haven't done an actual comparison of the
amount of fraud in the last seven
elections for example to show me that it
was the least in 2020 and yet that
became the mantra now on the
conservative side as you know a lot of
flying theories going about
anomalies uh episodic fraud i mean look
at this dead guy who voted over here
look at that guy was stuffing ballots
over there but of course the courts in
these situations
use the principle that can be called the
but for principle but for the fraud
would the election have come out
differently and that's a pretty high bar
you have to show a magnitude of fraud
and that was i never felt was really
done never shown never proven and so
again i thought let's move on this is
something that we might never know so it
wasn't until i sat down with the two
principles of the organization called
true the vote that i realized that they
had sort of approached the election like
a cold case like coal case files and
they figured out you know there actually
is a way to go back and and track the
movements of these so-called mules and
there is a way also to look uh through
surveillance video and in a sense take
us back to the days before and during
the 2020 election to actually see what
happened with your own two eyes
okay so before we get into some of the
specifics of how they use geotagging and
how they were actually tracking these
mules and i want you to actually define
what a mule is what you do in the movie
obviously how do you as a filmmaker
because you've obviously made a bunch of
documentaries before how do you make
sure that your own personal
opinions don't override the truth
because to me that's got to be the
hardest part i think there are moments
in the movie where you sort of address
that a little bit but to remove all of
your bias for all of us is almost
completely impossible
it is impossible and i would argue that
in terms of attaining that kind of pure
objectivity that's never going to happen
i mean that doesn't occur uh at all but
what you can do is try to have that sort
of
empathetic ability and it's a debating
ability by the way to always see the
strength of the counter-argument of the
other guy's point of view and import
that into the film also one of my
techniques here was
i recognized that among the kind of
salem podcast hosts i'm thinking of
people like eric mataxis and larry elder
there were a mix of views about the
election some of them it was stolen for
sure some of them yeah i haven't seen
any proof of it and i had the idea of
importing them into the movie uh having
their initial thoughts then showing them
the evidence and literally spontaneously
filming their reaction and then asking
them for their assessments i thought in
this way it goes beyond just sort of
dinesh's singular interpretation and it
becomes a conversation about the issue
in which it's possible that somebody
watching the movie would go you know i
see stronger ground in what uh larry
elder is saying than anything dinesh
might have said so by by doing it that
way it does what a good movie does which
is it lays out a narrative with a range
of positions and a range of potential
possible interpretations it was
interesting so you use this round table
of the salem host so it's it's you and
dennis prager and larry elder and eric
mataxis and charlie kirk am i forgetting
anyone oh and seb gorka and gordon
and you guys sort of spur you know you
guys come and go throughout the movie
discussing what's going on and it's
interesting because dennis i think comes
off as the most skeptical at the
beginning he kind of comes around a
little bit more but everyone's asking
questions throughout and obviously you
didn't cut the questions so uh
there's some credit there i mean in some
ways that's the best part where dennis
will say for example hey listen you know
you have a mule you're showing this guy
stuffing balance what if you run up to
him right now and grab his ballots and
look at them what would you see on the
ballot i mean what's cool about it to me
is i thought to myself those are the
kinds of questions that people in the
audience are going to be asking so by
putting them right in the movie the
movie doesn't have to come back and
answer those questions because they are
anticipated and addressed or at least
discussed in the film itself okay so for
the people that have not seen it yet
without blowing anything major can you
at least can you give the kind of
elevator pitch on the the methodology
that you guys were looking at related to
people's smartphones and where they were
going and just the the basic idea of
what 2000 mules is
sure the the film drawing on the work of
this group called true the vote a kind
of election intelligence group if you
will uh uses two independent modes of
investigation or two two modes of
argument the first one is cell phone geo
tracking
and that arises out of the simple point
that we're at a stage of technology now
and perhaps also a stage where we have
relinquished our privacy to a point now
where our movements can be tracked uh
they're tracked because of not because
of cell phone towers that are pinging
it's because of apps inside our phone
that allow so-called aggregators to
collect this data and by the way it's
sold on the open market commercial
companies can buy it it's also very
valuable to law enforcement intelligence
agencies but essentially if i was being
geotrack right now uh you could tell for
sure i woke up in my bedroom in my house
i then went to a coffee shop and i went
to the studio to record my podcast and i
had lunch with a friend at this
restaurant then i came home and all of
that is shown
not by a single snapshot of my phone but
by what's called a pattern of life
you're showing the movement of my cell
phone now obviously if i gave myself one
to my wife debbie it would show her
movements but that the cell phone is
making these movements and going to
these locations is really not open to
doubt and so what true the vote did is
they used the cell phone geo tracking
used in many other areas their kind of
genius idea was let's apply that to
ballot trafficking and what we're
looking for are these mules now what's a
mule
basically a paid operative who has
handed ballots
and asked to drop them off to deliver
them to uh mail and dropboxes and uh and
we've been able to identify based on a
criterion actually a very high criterion
mules going to 10 or more drop boxes
some 2 000 mules and that's where the
title of the movie comes from
right so you believe that there are way
more than 2 000 moves but you were just
focusing on this group that had this
very sort of high threshold and as you
show in the movie i mean a lot of these
people that were repeatedly going to
these drop boxes
they i mean they look like transients or
almost homeless people a lot of them
they're showing up at 4 00 a.m and 7 am
they kind of look disheveled um they in
other words they don't look like sort of
the upstanding citizen that's doing
their do
service for the country because they've
collected some ballots for you know some
people that can't you know drop the
ballots off themselves it doesn't come
off exactly like that
exactly now in the five states that we
look at which is georgia arizona
wisconsin michigan and pennsylvania
you don't have the kind of liberal vote
harvesting where you can give your
ballot to anyone and have them drop it
off that is the case by the way in
california but even in california you
can't pay people to deliver ballots i
can't say to my neighbor go drop off my
ballot here's 50 bucks because the
moment money comes in there's bribery
essentially the vote is contaminated and
even a legal vote becomes illegal when
money changes hands now in places like
georgia and arizona you can only give
your ballot to an immediate family
member or if you're confined to a
caregiver that's it and i think you can
see this is the power of the video the
second line of evidence in the movie is
you begin to see not just cell phone
devices moving from one dropbox to
another but you actually get to see the
mules and i think it's very telling
because when you see a guy jump out of a
car it's three in the morning he looks
left and right make sure i was looking
at him it has all the hallmarks to any
observer that this is an illicit and
nefarious operation being conducted
under cover of night
okay so even for someone that hasn't
seen the movie yet they're hearing you
they're going okay so let's get this
straight these guys have the phones
we're tracking these people they're
showing up repeatedly they look kind of
shady you've got video now some of them
are wearing masks because it was also
during covet or they were disguising
themselves but but a bunch of them you
can see their faces so
clearly we can figure out who these
people are so what kind of work have you
done or is ongoing to figure out who
they are and i guess the real question
is who paid them
right so they when you when you when you
see these mules operating you see that
they stop at organizations and that's
where they get the ballot so the mules
don't come up with their own ballots
they they go to what we call vote stash
houses and what are they well they turn
out to be kind of far left organizations
deeply embedded in the inner city places
like atlanta philadelphia detroit and so
on so they go to these places they get
the ballots and then to be clear though
because you actually show the map in the
movie you show them actually going to
these places before they're doing the
the drop off actually yeah not only that
but once they they go to three or four
drop boxes they need to get more ballots
so they go right back to the
organization sort of replenish and then
they continue now it's important to say
why they do this because you'd think
wait a minute if a mule is dumping 300
ballots why don't you go to one drop box
and just unload them save yourself a
whole bunch of trouble well the reason
is that the next morning the election
officials open these drop boxes and
let's say the typical dropbox has like
80 ballots and then this one dropbox has
like 700 ballots you'd know right away
something is up so the mules are
instructed not to do that they dropped
five ballots here eight ballots there
that's why they go on these routes and
that of course makes them easier to
track the reason the truth the votes
research i think is so powerful here is
they set such a high bar 10 or more drop
boxes because see let's say that they
had set a bar of two drop boxes now
nobody has a reason to go to two even if
you have your family members ballots
you're gonna go put them in one drop box
but some guy was gonna come forward and
say well you know what i i put my
ballots in the first box i had to tie my
shoe at the second box so you're calling
me a mule i'm not a mule so instead of
all this nonsense set a bar of 10 or
more drop boxes let's remember these
aren't this is in the post office this
isn't where you're going to drop your
bills off these are only for balance
there's no other reason to go to these
drop boxes other than to dump ballots
and why would you go to 10 or more drop
boxes unless you were stuffing them with
ballots so that's the sort of
technological reasoning behind the power
of the geo-tracking evidence now i wish
we had more video but true the vote does
have four million minutes of video so
they have a lot but unfortunately a lot
of dropboxes don't have video
right so are they going through more
video now because there is you have some
people you have their faces i mean have
they been doing any work to track these
people do you do you know where any of
these people are i mean again a lot of
them sort of seem like transients or
just
probably unidentifiable for one reason
or another but there's got to be some
way to get some of them right well
here's the key point i mean obviously
you're right some of these mules are
visible you can see their face and they
can be recognized that way but the more
important thing is that true the vote
has the cell phone ids of all the mules
all the 2000 mules so when you track a
cell phone each cell phone has a unique
kind of digital fingerprint the cell
phone id each cell phone has only one id
and it's about as good technologically
as having you know a finger human
fingerprint or even human dna that's the
same degree of reliability now
interestingly true the vote doesn't have
the names of these mules but law
enforcement they unmask these cell
phones all the time so unmasking simply
means you go to a judge you say hey
listen i've got these guys a 10 or more
drop boxes so i have probable cause the
judge goes here's a warrant you go to
the cell phone provider they give you
the names of all the mules and then you
go interview them you know who paid you
who put you up to it and so on
so where are you at in that process
so where we are is that truth the vote
has been working hard with the state of
georgia but there's a very
subtle and complex investigation and
it's not clear that the secretary of
state raffensberger who's leading this
investigation is trying to push it
forward or hold it back he's involved in
a very complex politics inside of
georgia now in yuma county arizona the
sheriff just announced unknown to us
that there's a new investigation into
criminal ballot trafficking in yuma and
this is of course important because in
the movie we interview a mule where is
she from san luis inside of yuma county
true the vote has done work in yuma for
months so while the sheriff goes i'm not
doing it because of a movie and frankly
we wouldn't want him to say any
differently here is a guy who has been
checking into this and in a sense it
provides a certain independent
validation that this is a legitimate
issue this kind of ballot trafficking
does go on and it is a crime
what has been
sort of what you would say is the most
legit criticism of the movie that you've
seen you know i've seen a lot of just
sort of oh here's dinesh peddling the
big lie actually like a minute before we
connected on skype i saw that you
tweeted out it was a criticism from i
think it was like a former fbi guy who
basically just said oh dinesh's big live
movies going to the theaters but there's
no criticism of the movie it's just sort
of this blanket criticism but i'm sure
you've heard some things that have that
have brought up issues or maybe things
that you wish you addressed etc there
are two very uh plausible and legitimate
criticisms and i've tried to address
both one was brought up by megyn kelly
um and it was basically this um where do
the ballots come from so in other words
we know that they come from the
nonprofits but where do the nonprofits
get them are these are these legal votes
that are being delivered in an illegal
way or are these fraudulent and illegal
votes in the first place that are also
being delivered in a fraudulent way and
dennis sort of brings that up in the
movie doesn't he as well
yeah we address this directly in the
movie and what we say is in a sense we
cannot know for sure because we're
tracking the ballot from the dropbox
back and we know the origination point
is the non-profit so we know the
non-profits are paying the mules now
where do the non-profits get the ballots
now the problem here is this i cannot
think if you were talking about a
hundred ballots i could say well you
know what some nonprofit went through a
housing complex they collected
everybody's ballot well we're talking
about hundreds of thousands of ballots
being collected in five separate states
so i say to myself what is the what is
the plausible scenario of a legal voter
say dave rubin or dinesh saying you know
what i'm feeling a little lazy today i
don't want to go down to the mail and
drop box i'm going to go to a left-wing
non-profit in the inner city give them
my lawful ballot so they can hire a mule
to go in the middle of the night wearing
gloves and take photos of the ballots
going in it makes no sense so there's i
cannot think of any plausible way for
these to be all legal ballots so my
guess is it's a mixture of legal and
illegal ballots but all these ballots
are rendered fraudulent by the simple
fact that the mules are being paid and
and that
paid ballot trafficking is illegal in
all 50 states
so you mentioned the take a picture
thing so that is one of the interesting
things that many times almost every time
the way they get paid is they have to
take a picture as they're putting the
ballots in otherwise obviously for all
they know the nonprofit thinks that
they're just dumping the ballot
somewhere um would there be any other
reason to take a picture i mean is there
any
reason someone might take i mean other
than for instagram purposes or something
well this is the key point so washington
post philip bump and others have
basically said it's not uncommon for
people to take selfies to show that they
voted they're really proud of their
citizenship they want to show that they
participated but see that involves
taking a picture of yourself right right
you see the mule standing behind the
camera taking a photo of the ballot
going in so again you have to and the
same thing with the gloves if there were
gloves from early voting october 1 all
the way through the georgia runoffs
january 5th then you'd go well maybe
it's covid but when you see that there
are no gloves all the way in early
voting and on election day and the
gloves only show up in the georgia
runoffs immediately following an
indictment in arizona where the fbi
busts a criminal ring of ballot
traffickers by finding their
fingerprints on multiple ballots well
which theory is a better explanation of
those facts the covet theory or the
theory that the word went out among the
mules guys you better start wearing
latex gloves
what should we know about these
non-profits and and sort of where
they're getting their funding and are
they coordinating it with each other i
mean are they is this just you know
these happen to be a bunch of left-wing
things that are all kind of doing the
same thing i mean do we know how
connected they are well what's really
interesting dave and we we have scott
walter from capital research center in
the movie talks about this a big river
of cash goes to these left-wing
non-profits right before the election
and this is a little bit strange because
non-profits are by law forbidden from
engaging in explicit electioneering they
can generally exhort people be a good
citizen get out and vote but they're not
allowed to do any politicking that will
benefit any particular candidate or
party and the irs could not be more
clear about this so why would you have
this large river of cash coming from all
these foundations coming from soros
coming from warren buffett flowing into
these non-profits when these non-profits
are supposed to as i say be neutrals in
the election process so i don't see this
as a quote conspiracy what i see rather
going on is there's a coordination on
the left and among the democrats to sort
of enable the heist so consider like
mark zuckerberg he puts all this money
in and he uses it as financial leverage
to get all these mail and drop boxes
some of these cities weren't planning on
having these this many drop boxes but
zuckerberg is you want my money you need
to put up all these drop boxes and if
you don't do it you're gonna have to
give my money back so you have a private
citizen unbelievably infiltrating
election offices and using his financial
muscle to get to essentially run the way
the election is conducted in 2020. now
again i'm not saying zuckerberg knew
about the mules i'm assuming he didn't
but think of it if he didn't fund the
drop boxes the mules wouldn't have a
place to go to
dinesh it was only 400 million dollars
that he personally gave to fortify the
election are you saying 400 million
dollars might have ticked this thing a
little dave you gotta you're talking to
a guy who spent eight months in
overnight confinement for giving twenty
thousand dollars to a college friend of
mine i was found in violation of the
campaign finance laws i was basically
you know uh locked up overnight so when
i see the amount of money that these
guys are able to put in now quite
frankly the part of the genius of what
zuckerberg did is i can't find a law
that says you can't do that i think in a
way the audacity of that move is that
nobody even anticipated that actual
state laws that govern elections could
somehow be manipulated from the outside
by a guy coming in essentially with a
sack full of cash so see all of that
enabled the heist but it doesn't mean
there was a heist if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell